stand from delving deeper into linda
Anderson's story what's your takeaway on
her life whether you consider her the
victim the victimizer I think she's both
I think Linda Anderson which is what
makes the movie interesting is both the
victim and the villain as a parent
myself that's what drew me to the
material is that kind of gray area that
everybody lives in in this movie there
are no heroes there are no villains
everybody lives in kind of that place
between being a hero and being a villain
and I was kind of interested to see if I
could keep the audience from feeling one
way or the other somebody wearing a
black hat or a white hat and Linda
Anderson I think tries hard but makes
them very very very big mistakes in
creating a home life for girls that lead
them to a place where they think there's
only one way out right and you do keep
her somewhat likable definitely
throughout the film and I love how you
have the fantasy mom image throughout I
think that's great which brings me to my
next question as you mentioned you know
you were drawn to the story but you're a
producer for 30 years what was your
decision now to go and be the director
of this film I had made so many movies
and had reached kind of the pinnacle
after winning an Emmy and being
nominated multiple times and I really
wanted to try and direct and see if I
could do it after all this time after
complaining about directors that have
worked for me and so decided finally to
take that shot and it was this piece of
material that I'd originally developed
as a television movie that was just far
too dark to make and so I'd put it on
the shelf and but it always kind of
nagged at me and I felt like it was the
most compelling story I knew out there
that I could make at a price and get my
first shot
you